the bouet thing to me is so silly like
we're a bunch of grown men talking about
other men's feet like is this politics
now this this is the important
thing I've heard the the argument about
you know integrity and honesty and you
should be honest about yourself and if
you you have to wear you know lifts if
it was some type of decision made by
your team to be yure taller than you
said yes to it well maybe you shouldn't
have said yes to that I think it's
because you can't take a joke I don't
care how tall you are it's just like
that him or the team can't take J show
inse security and it also shows who sta
himself with right like again I thought
D santis would have been a good VP pick
uh I'm not I I am very loathed to short
anyone when potentially we have a long
long time it's going to take decades to
turn America around in my opinion but
yes uh you know with all of everything
that's happened in boot gate it just
makes it seem like he is around people
who do not feel confident with doing and
so in response they're on an attack mode
and I think that's what makes Trump in
comparison even more attractive to
voters